militant feminists Jodie Allard is back
at it after writing a piece essentially
calling her sons complicit in rape
culture after I offered one of her sons
an internship I know he sends a resume
he would through a late last week for an
internship for unspecified reasons
allard has now written a follow-up
attempting to explain herself she wants
to explain why writing nasty things
about her children is not quote unquote
abusive first she explains people are
misinterpreting the terms rape culture
and toxic masculinity she doesn't mean
that all men are potential rapists she
only means that society promulgates the
belief that women are blamed for sexual
violence and misogyny
well normalizing sexual violence and
aggression she also says toxic
masculinity it only means that society
has visions of masculinity that are
toxic yes that is much better Jodie I'm
sure your sons will be very very
grateful for your clarification man she
moves on to her explanation about why
she would invoke her own sons in
attacking these pernicious structures
here's what she writes quote with those
definitions out of the way it should be
clear that discussing how particular men
even my children absorb these cultural
ideas is in no way abusing them well she
did a little bit more than that her
original piece said this about her own
sons quote I don't feel emotionally safe
with them and perhaps never have with a
man but it needs to be said because far
too often we are afraid to say it those
little boys grow into men who know the
value of women the value that's been
ascribed to us by a broken system and it
seeps out from them in a million tiny
toxic ways according to a learned oh
she's just educating her kids in the
pages of the nation's largest newspapers
should I encourage my sons to reflect on
their own cultural indoctrination into
racism sexism ableism etc without shame
without shame in the pages of the
Washington Post she wrote direct quote
my sons are part of the problem that is
not education and that is public shaming
she then reiterates her central
contention that men always make women
feel emotionally unsafe which is kind of
weird given the functioning
relationships between billions of men
and women in the history of the planet
but Allerton contends quote the
heartbreaking part is that even good men
can't be fully or completely safe for
women even when they're our own flesh
and blood she concludes quote there's no
doubt that writing about this journey
opens my family up to examination and
criticism however it's better to suggest
that my sons are the ones bearing the
burden except that they are which is
presumably why one of her son sent me a
resume even if you later withdrew from
consider
and ben shapiro this is a Ben Shapiro
show so many things to get to today
weird things happening right before the
show that we will have to discuss on air
to the detriment of one of the new
producers over here a fellow named
Marshall but we will discuss all of that
in just a few moments first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
ring so rings mission is to make
neighborhoods safer the summertime is
when a lot of home burglaries actually
go up because people are out of the
house for longer periods of time and
what they usually do burglars are very
often what they do is they bring the
front doorbell
and then if some nobody answers they
assume nobody tell them they break in
what ring allows you to do to video
doorbell so when you ring it pops up on
your phone you can see their face you
can talk to them you can act like you're
at homes they don't rob your house also
they have this amazing new floodlight
cam which extends the security for the
rest of your room your home rather since
what like cam motion-activated camera it
connects right to your phone with HD
video two-way audio letting you know the
moment anyone sets foot on your property
you can see and speak to visitors even
set up an alarm right from your phone
and with that floodlight can when things
go bump in the night you'll immediately
know what it is and who it is
ring public offers the ultimate in home
security with high visibility
floodlights and that powerful HD camera
with ring you are always home save up to
one hundred and fifty dollars off a ring
of security kit when you go to ring calm
slash pen ring calm slash Ben again
everybody is getting it in the LA area
we had a handyman come over the other
day and he said you know you already
have ringing said yeah I said if you
hadn't that's my number one seller right
now ring calm / Ben and he in it makes
your home completely safe for people
like me I'm I'm very paranoid about
security excited little kids in the home
it makes me feel safe particularly when
I'm on the road because I can even pick
this up if I'm in New York or something
so nobody knows that I'm not at home
okay so I want to get to the mooch this
is this is scaramouche e Anthony Skinner
Moochie is the new press head a head of
press over at the Trump administration
he probably will end up as chief of
staff because Trump looks like he's
getting ready to clear house I've heard
from Marshall that he is very hot right
now or he's hot or something I don't
understand I don't understand what in
the world that was this morning Marshall
who is new here turns to me and says
mooch is hot right I was like what just
what now what what
mmm-hmm what I regret nothing okay thank
you for that Marshall I'm glad you
regret nothing you might win your
paycheck fails to come next week in any
case we'll get to the mascara mochi at
the White House in just a moment because
it does say something about where the
where the Trump administration is and
where they are going there's a lot of
turnover I also want to get to Jared
Kushner because Jared Kushner finally
put out an 11-page statement he's
supposed to give it before Congress
today he's supposed to testify and it
really does give the lie to a lie if
what he's saying is true then the media
have been fibbing this whole time which
would not be a tremendous shot but I
want to start today with the situation
over in Israel so over in Israel there
has been been riots there was a
situation over the weekend in which an
evil 20 year old Palestinian Arab went
into a Jewish home broke into a Jewish
home they're a bunch of five kids at
home I think and they were celebrating
the birth of a new boy and they're
having what's called a Shalom johor
which is a celebration that you have
when there's a newborn baby boy and
people were over and after that it was
late at night and the the grandparents
and the parents were sitting in and
talking and the Palestinian air broke
into the house and stabbed to death all
three three of the four people the other
the fourth person was stabbed as well so
three people are murdered in their own
home here's a picture of the floor so
people should see what this looks like
it's just horrifying and that's that is
the the family's blood all over the
floor
the Palestinian Arab was shot to death
by an off-duty soldier who came running
from next door the reason that all of
this happened why did all of this happen
this happened because there are two
pound three Palestinians who invaded the
Temple Mount with guns shot two Israeli
Druze police officers they weren't
Jewish they're Druze which is different
religion and and killed them this is
last week and Israel and response said
hey we're going to put some metal
detectors by the entrance to the Temple
Mount that's what we're going to do okay
now we have metal detectors here in the
United States everywhere right we have
them at the airport we have them at
ballgames we have them at some offices
we have the public schools now have you
ever heard of a riot over a metal
detector
well Palestinians decided it was very
important to riot over the metal
detectors here's a poster of what they
were what we're saying and you can see
that they are cheering the the so-called
uprising hours before that murderous
attack Fatah encouraged Palestinians
about saw by the way
military arm of the Palestinian
Authority to rage and called for
escalation and glorified death and says
if I fall I will not be the first to die
and not the last to die
hashtag rage hashtag Friday of dignity
this is the Palestinian government okay
this is not a terrorist group is the
Palestinian government military arm and
some people say that Israel has a peace
partner that an absolute absolute horse
crap it is not true at all you want to
see Israel's Palestinian peace partner
here's the mother of the twenty year old
who murdered a family for no reason
other than because he had been whipped
up to rage by his own government over
the installation of metal detectors at a
holy site that Israel allows Muslims to
keep control of for no apparent reason
here's the mother and then obeys Allah I
am proud of my son Islam may Allah be
pleased with him okay so she's praising
her son who had killed in the terrorist
attack after murdering three innocent
people just horrific all the way around
and should be demonstrative of the fact
that when it comes to this so-called
cycle of violence there's only one side
that wants to engage in random violence
and Cheers there okay the government of
the Palestinians cheers this stuff there
is no moral equivalence here anybody who
says there is lying to you you're
looking at the face of evil right here
her son is an evil person and the
Palestinian government is evil as well
it is just horrifying on every level
okay so in other news back in the United
States the the important news is a the
Jared Kushner Trump's son-in-law is
supposed to speak today before
congressional committees and his
testimony explains all of his contacts
with various Russian government
connected sources over the course of the
campaign and the transition and it's
very plausible I mean honestly when I
read I believe it it's absent extra
evidence absent external evidence of
malfeasance or bad action I'm not seeing
anything here that suggests to me
anything nefarious between Kushner and
the Russian government for example now
there are apparently some financial
relationships between the Trump
Organization and Russian government
sources I'll talk about that in a second
but cushion' airs full scale summary of
what exactly happened here is worth
going through because the media is
giving you the headline but they're not
giving you the truth the media as always
is exaggerating the Russia stuff so what
the media headlines today say things
like cushion or took for Russia meetings
says no collusion okay but that's not
the D that's not the full explanation I
mean the reality is what he says that
these meetings were basically
nothing so for example he says when it
became apparent that my father-in-law
was going to be the Republican nominee
for president as normally happens a
number of officials from foreign
countries attempted to reach out to the
campaign my father-in-law asked me to be
a point of contact with these foreign
countries these were not contact I had
initiated but over the course of the
campaign I had incoming contacts with
people from approximately 15 countries
his first meeting with Russia or Russian
representatives during the campaign
occurred in April 2016 at the Mayflower
Hotel this is the same meeting where
apparently jeff sessions met the russian
ambassador
he said winner said he met four
ambassadors including Sergei Kissel yet
we shook hands exchanged pleasantries
and I thank them for attending the event
he said this lasted less than a minute
okay that was the source of a number of
headlines over the course of last few
months then there was a report from
Reuters that he done a couple of phone
calls with kiss plea act he says we
checked all of our phone records I have
no information about this I even asked
Reuters what the dates were so I could
check it I don't remember this happening
and I have no evidence of it happening
then there is the second meeting with
the Russians okay so the second meeting
with the Russians was the infamous
Donald Trump jr. meeting that was one
where every Russian in the Western
Hemisphere came to this meeting and that
was the one where Donald Trump jr. said
that he was going to that he was hopeful
that there'd be information about
Hillary Clinton from the Russian
government militia nur says I had no
idea what this was it was listen my
calendar as done junior meeting I went
there it was a big nothing they were
talking about adoption by the time I got
there and I even wrote my assistance in
email but said can you please call me on
my cell need excuse to get out of
meeting he thought it was enough of a
waste of time but he picked a phone call
to get out of the meeting which is
something that I do pretty much every
day here at the Daily wire then finally
he says that there was a third contact
from a Rando emailer that meant nothing
in he reported The Secret Service then
there was a meeting on December 1st at
Trump Tower with kis lyac and Michael
Flynn and this is the one that a lot of
people are circulating around at that
meeting history accent he wanted to
address US policy in Syria and that he
wanted to convey information from what
he called his generals kiss react hold
Kushner the generals couldn't make it
over to the United States and wanted to
use a secure line in the transition
office Kushner said there was none and
asked if they had an existing
communications channel at the Embassy we
could use or they would be comfortable
transmitting the information they wanted
to relay to general Flynn so as you
recall there was a big story about how
cushion wanted to set up a secret back
channel to talk with the Russians from
the Russian embassy and it was such a
weird suggestion that even the Russians
taken aback by it well apparently what
this basically is it sounds like winners
just an idiot right Kushner said they
said to him you have a secure line he
said no do you have a secure line and
that was the extent of the conversation
and so did that sound like something
nefarious no it doesn't and then finally
December 13 collection errs they met
with a person named Sergei Gourcuff who
said he was a banker at the request of
Kissel a act here's Kushner's account to
the meeting the meeting with mr.
Gourcuff lasted twenty to twenty-five
minutes he introduced himself and gave
me two gifts one was a piece of art from
nimrod the village where my grandparents
were from in belarus and the other was a
bag of dirt from that same village which
is an awesome gift I've tried it with my
wife I just got to the garden get a
garbage bag put some dirt in it I'm like
happy Anniversary sweetheart
any notion that I tried to conceal this
meeting or that I took it thinking it
was in my capacity as a businessman is
false in fact I gave my assistant these
gifts to formally register them with the
transition office that's got to be fun
you walk in with the transition officer
like one bag of dirt okay after that he
told me a little about his bank and made
some statements about the Russian
economy he said he was friendly with
Putin expressed disappointment with
us-russia relations under Obama and
hopes for a better relationship in the
future there were no specific policies
involved and no time was there any
discussion about my company's business
transactions real estate projects loans
banking arrangements or any private
business of any kind at the end of the
short meeting we thanked each other and
I went on to other meetings it's
interesting here though the one thing he
doesn't say is that there was no talk
about Trump's investments because Gore
Cobb leads up a bank called VEB which is
a Russian bank under scrutiny by US
investigators that finance the deal is
according to The Wall Street Journal
that financed a deal involving Trump's
one-time partner in the Toronto hotel
tower at a key moment for the project so
the gore cop of all the meetings the
glory cop one is the most suspicious but
none of them is enough to really raise
tremendous hackles at this point absent
any sort of outside information which
suggested media have been blowing
everything out of proportion a big
question here is why kosher didn't just
come out and say that's a while and
they'll write I mean it's so innocent
then why wouldn't cushion or just come
out and spill this right all these
stories came out months ago you could
have just said that meeting with Kissel
a act here's what I said not a big deal
calm down instead they let that simmer
in rage for months at a time and again
there's been there have been too many
updates in the recent past about things
that Trump and his team have said for us
to take everything at face value but
this is a very plausible story I don't
see
anything here that looks suspicious and
again there's no evidence that Kushner
at least was colluding with the Russians
meanwhile President Trump is feeling
more and more under siege and you can
see that he's very angry because he
feels like people are not defending him
enough now it's hard to defend the
president and his son after his son says
things to the Russian government like I
love it in an email exchange in which
they offer support to them it's hard to
defend Trump from that it's hard to
defend Trump when Trump Kara falls
through Remy's are things that are hard
to defend it's hard to defend him on
Syrian policy I'm happy to defend him
when I think he's doing the right thing
or where I think that the media have
been lying about him so that's why I'm
defending him on the cushion her stuff
because I see no evidence that Kushner
is lying
and so the media's attempt to play that
as cushion air is some sort of nefarious
Russian source I think it's a bunch of
nonsense that's not stopping Trump
though like he's tweeting out how he
feels really under attack I don't like
the whiny stuff from the president he's
a powerful man on earth he has a bully
pulpit at his disposal is no person in
the history of mankind has had and yet
he's treating this as though he's a
victim he says the phony Russian
witch-hunt continues two groups are
laughing at this excuse for a lost
election taking hold Democrats and
Russians okay that's fine that doesn't
bother me this is the part that bothers
me as is very sad that Republicans even
some that were carried over the line on
my back very little to protect their
president okay first of all the idea
that he that it is Republicans job to
quote unquote protect the president when
it is his job to tell the truth about
things does not seem to me correct also
this idea that carried people over the
line there's legitimately maybe one guy
in the United States you carry over the
line electoral may Roy Blunt in Missouri
every other race Trump ran behind Senate
candidates in congressional candidates
in fact Trump was a drag on the ticket a
little bit that's just the statistical
fact so this idea that everybody should
be very grateful to him for their jobs
it's just not true and again it's whiney
like if you have something that you want
to say just say it it's hard to read the
failing New York Times with the MS on
Washington Post because every story
opinion even if it should be positive is
bad again I agree with all the stuff but
it's getting boring at this point I
think that you know the fact is that all
these newspapers have always been
against Republicans and finally says if
Republicans don't repeal and replace the
disastrous Obama care the repercussions
will be far greater than any of them
understand yeah I don't even know if
that means and what the repercussions
are supposed to be and he hasn't
proposed a plan so again mr. president
please buckle down to business and
but the world's tiniest violin routine
one of the things that I said when they
appointed a special prosecutor on all
this Russia stuff is now would be a good
time to shut up just stop your stop
talking right now be a perfect time for
you to sit back let the investigation
take place you can say listen it's
moving forward I'm not at liberty to
discuss it nobody's a liberty to discuss
it he's doing what he's going to do
it'll be what its going to be end of
story
instead it continues to foment and it
continues to foment because Trump
insists on doing stuff like this from
people who think that this is the sort
of fighting back that we need let me
just ask why this is productive like his
base I understand is very enthusiastic
about all of this but I don't understand
why this is productive in forwarding his
point of view like we all understand
where he stands on this stuff right we
all get it but Trump is starting to
create an administration that is solely
designed around guarding him personally
and guarding his ego personally and
that's not how things are going to get
done for people who want things to get
done who want him to be a good president
and yes things have to get done in order
for him to be a good president he's
going to need to focus less on defending
his own ego and more on promulgating
policy but people like he's doing some
good things I mean I talked about this
last week the regulatory cuts the fact
that there is a 16 to 1 ratio between
regulations that are being cut and new
ones that are being imposed that's a
really good thing more of that more
judicial appointments more cabinet
appointments more tax policy there are
lots of things that Trump could be doing
right now more religious freedom
legislation there's lots of good things
that are very important in terms should
be doing right now they're not getting
done because Trump is engaged with Trump
and I think the scarer Moochie
appointment is is some of that for sure
I'm going to scare Moochie appointment
in just a second the world's hottest man
according Marshall but before I get to
any of that I first want to say thanks
to our sponsors over at 5 4 clubs so
this is awesome looking good does not
have to cost you a ton of money 5-4 club
is revolutionizing the way people shop
because the way that it works they send
you each month a curated box of 2 to 3
items that are hand-picked to match the
current season and your style you go on
their website you kind of pick your
style what you like to look good and
they've been helping men with fashion
for over 15 years and they ship to over
100,000 men every month they know what
they're doing 5 4 Club will help you
build your wardrobe one month at a time
right now you get 120 dollars worth of
clothes for just $60 a month and you can
pause or cancel that anytime so it's no
commitment you also receive 50% off up
to 50% off
in their online shop and access to
exclusive members on the items free
shipping and size exchanges see make
sure that you get the best clothes that
you can again it doesn't cost you a
fortune to look good these are all items
that look like name-brand products you
just don't have to pay the extra markup
for the name-brand go to five four
club.com right now and enter promo code
been yet to spell out the number such fi
ve fo you are club.com promo code been
when you do that they will give you 50%
off your first month package plus a free
pair of sunglasses pretty solid deal
just for signing up five for club.com
right now enter that promo code band 50%
off your first package five for club.com
promo code ben and again it's fi ve fo
you are club comm and you use that promo
code then and that's how you get to look
excellent because that's what the ladies
actually enjoy apparently I've been told
this okay so Anthony Sierra Moochie is
the new White House communications
director Sean Spicer is out that broke
very late breaking news on Friday and so
here are a few things you need to know
about Anthony scare emoji and this is
indicative of where the administration
is going to go Anthony scare emoji gives
a lot of money to Democrats now that's
not a shock Trump gave lots of money to
Democrats but until 2010 he maxed out
for Obama in 2008 he gave money to a
bevy of Democrats he is a Wall Street
hedge fund manager he's sort of mini
Trump like he ran a capital group called
skybridge capital it has underperformed
the market but he's really big in the
press and he likes to talk big on TV
he's known as being a media savant he's
known as the muj which is always a great
nickname he has described his politics
being socially inclusive and fiscally
responsible so he has tweeted out a lot
of things that are very much to the left
he tweeted out in 2012 but we the USA
has 5% of the world's population but 50%
of the world's guns enough is enough it
is just common sense it applies it
applied more controls so he wants more
gun control he's also said that he's
also said that he is for gay marriage
against the death penalty and pro-choice
so there's that he says he favors a plan
that provides universal health care
but we've but better than Obamacare he
was critical of Trump in 2015 he had to
apologize to Trump actually and now he
has become a very ardent supporter on
Trump over and over he has defended
Trump so he is he's a drunken I mean
that that's basically his job his job is
to praise Trump and to look like a Wall
Street guy while doing it my own
assessment of his hotness is that as
Marshall was asked my own assessments of
his hotness
is that as someone online said he looks
like an extra from the wolf of Wall
Street who wouldn't stop badgering Leo
DiCaprio for a selfie that's sort of the
feeling that you get from Anthony scare
Moochie he did a good job in his first
press conference because he's much
smoother than Sean Spicer he certainly
reflects Trump a lot better than Sean
Spicer and he is not afraid to kids a
little Trump ass that is for sure
so this is this is an astonishing Club
so this is scary Moochie from the press
conference on Friday and here is
scaramouche appraising Trump in terms
that would make Kim jong-un blush but
here's what I tell you the president
he's the most competitive person I've
ever met
okay I've seen this guy throw a dead
spiral through a tire I've seen him at
Madison Square Garden or the top coat on
he's standing in the key and he's
hitting foul shots and swishing them
okay he sinks three foot putts
I don't see this guy is the guy that's
ever under siege this is a very very
competitive person obviously there's a
lot of incoming that comes into the
White House but the president's a winner
okay and what we're going to do is we're
going to do a lot of winning oh except
these were that I've seen this guy I
mean it does sound like a Kim jong-un
promo like for a while in North Korea
they were saying to Kim jong-un have the
lowest score ever in golf that he had
scored an 18 in golf that he had 18
holes in one like this is part of the
legend of Kim Jong moon his unicorn lair
and he scores 18 in golf because every
hole is all in one that that's basically
and even throw a spiral right through a
tire I mean he just goes out there like
Brett Favre and his Wrangler jeans in
his off days I mean the man can throw it
70 yards on a dime boom hit the guy
right in the hand it's unbelievable and
when he plays basketball I mean he's got
a hook that would make Kareem just blush
he's incredible you see him on the
offensive glass pounding those boards
incredible have you ever seen him in
baseball he goes 173 miles an hour and
that's his curve he's unreal it's just
like wet right now so I understand that
this is that basically every time
anybody from Trump administration is on
TV they're on TV for Trump right I mean
that's what they do for a living it's
not about getting out Trump's met
per say is more about getting out a
message to Trump that you are loyal to
Trump and so now Trump is surrounding
himself with lots of Louis now that said
scaramouche is much better at his job
because apparently he has no shame I
mean if you can get on TV and say stuff
like that with a straight face good for
you dude I mean that's pretty impressive
he I do love this though he obviously
scorns the press he obviously just like
he's willing to slap the press a little
bit this was the end of his little
presser on Friday son s thank you
it looked blows the maquettes he blows
them a kiss at the very end it's pretty
amazing so that's that's pretty
incredible
gara mochi is in what this means that
he's going to parrot the worst excesses
of Trump so basically this Trump
administration so far the concessions
that Trump has made to the conservative
wing have been pushed out of him I would
say they're not coming from the heart I
think it's hard to say that the Trump is
in his guts a conservative person on
regulations I think you don't have to
push him very hard because as a business
person he suffered with regulations for
his entire career in real estate but I
think that when it comes to things like
Obamacare when it comes to things like
judge course the gentleman see these are
things he cares about particularly much
and so he sort of delegated them out the
people who force him to the right are
the ones who are now on the outs with
him because every time Trump feels like
he's being mobilized for a policy he
feels like he's being used and he
doesn't like being used and so his new
shtick is to surround himself with
people who agree with him on who were
going to pat him on the back that's not
really good for his administration I'm
going to explain what that means in just
a second but for that you're going to
have to go over to Daley wire.com for
$9.99 a month you can subscribe we are
not just an audio show we are a video
shows you can watch it live you can see
the entire show you can see my
magnificent outfits every day you can
see all of the clips including that one
of Skinner motor which is just fantastic
you can see all of these there's going
to be some video later you're gonna want
to see actually so you want to subscribe
for that plus you get Andrew Clavin
fantastic show live and you get his you
get his mailbag it's a part of his
mailbag get my mail back Michael Knowles
is launching a show what is the next
week now so next Monday Michael Knowles
is launching a show god help us that's
not the name of the show it's not called
god help us but he is launching a show
god help us Marshall was the producer on
that show which explains a lot and and
so that and so you can get that show
live as well when you go for daily we're
calm and subscribe once you get the site
ad free or if you just want the annual
subscription
which is even better than you for $99 a
year you get all of those things plus
this incredible magnificent let's just
here's tumblr it says upon it in silvery
letters leftist years hot or cold it is
something you'll treasure for years to
come hand down to your children one day
as I say they will find it in a cave
next to a crying baby doll after the
apes have taken over and the Statue of
Liberty just down the block in any case
it will last the test of time it will
last beyond you you'll be dead but this
mug will still be there so you're going
to want this thing it's just fantastic
you can bequeath it to all of your all
your all your later children in any case
get that for $99 a year over at daily
wire.com or just want to listen later go
to iTunes or SoundCloud and subscribe to
me that's review we always appreciate it
and we will see you on the other side
here
[Music]
so this morning president when I said
that Trump is looking to make some
changes in his administration there are
rumors today that Rex Tillerson the
Secretary of State is going to be out by
the end of the year that would be a good
thing as Rex Tillerson sucks his
Secretary of State who is a crappy pick
in the beginning I opposed his pick in
the beginning and so that would be a
good move a bad move however would be
getting rid of Jeff Sessions so the fact
is that the the Jeff Sessions is is one
of the more conservative members of his
administration there's a reason tucker
carlson and ann coulter are working on
on president Trump on this and trying to
get him to back off the sessions but
sessions is a great case in point of
what Trump is doing right Trump is and
great sessions not because he thinks
he's doing a bad job
I think sessions is doing a bad job on
asset forfeiture on simple asset
forfeiture which is this idea that if
you are picked up on a crime the
government can just seize your property
which is a crazy crazy law but sessions
has ramped that up that however is not
like Trump is angry him Trump is angry
at him because he's not protecting him
from the Russia stuff so he tweeted this
morning about four hours ago quote so
why aren't the committees and
investigators and of course our
beleaguered Attorney General looking
into crooked Hillary's crimes and
Russian relations okay first of all our
beleaguered attorney general is mostly
beleaguered by Trump at this point and
this idea that he should be looking into
crooked Hillary crimes in Russia
relations
President Trump is one pledged that
sessions would not do that if he was
appointed plus sessions works for him so
he could just call him into the office
and say I want you to investigate this
or I'm going to fire you but he's
basically just trying to push sessions
out at this point he's angry at sessions
as he said to the New York Times because
sessions recused himself on the Russia
stuff sessions is one of the more
conservative members of the
administration sessions is on the out
Bandhan apparently is on the outs Reince
Priebus the Republican Lackey who's the
chief of staff he's on the answers talk
about scarer Meucci basically taking
over over the weekend scaramouche II was
on one of the weekend shows and he said
that if he finds leakers in the White
House he doesn't just mean in the
Communications Office anywhere in the
White House I'll fire them that's the
language of the chief of staff's you've
got this career Democrat scaramouche II
who only in the last seven years started
campaigning with like Romney and then
Jeb Bush he is now going to be the chief
of staff I think is the direction this
is moving as I say a lot of the
conservative influences like sessions
are going to be out there is a rumor
I'm Rudy Giuliani would be nominated for
the post another New Yorker zoom in more
than most New York administration in
human history
I like Rudy Giuliani but putting
Giuliani in is just another person
surrounding Trump who is going to not
stop Trump from his own excesses
scaramouche II himself clearly is not
going to do that I mean he was on one of
the sunday shows and here was Skinner
Moochie saying I mean this is just in
confidence actually this is scaramouche
II saying that somebody told him that
the Russians didn't hack and then when
Pratt he gives an answer somebody said
to me yesterday I won't tell you who
that if the Russians actually hack this
situation and spilled out those those
emails you would have never seen it you
would have never had any evidence of
them meaning that they're super
confident in their deception skills and
hacking my point is all of the
information isn't on the table yet but
here's what I know about Anthony Anthony
finish we make a lot of assertions here
you I don't know who this anonymous
person is it said that if the Russians
had actually done it we wouldn't have
been able to detect it but it is the
data that it was that it was the
president okay it's the cleitophon I
usually call me he called me from Air
Force One yeah and he basically said to
me hey you know this is it maybe they
did it maybe they didn't do it on insane
insane okay so he starts off that
conversation with I'm not going to tell
you who it is it's the president
okay there's a problem with doing this
okay number one it was an actual Russian
talking point the Russians are now
confirming and so are people in the room
that Putin actually said to trump if we
attack you wouldn't know about it
because they'd be so good at it and now
it's Karamu cheese saying the Trump is
repeating those talking points to scare
Moochie I understand the Trump is
frustrated with the Russian stuff shut
up dude it's not worth it okay just
pursue your agenda you've got the
Republican Party behind you that's as
much as you're going to have behind you
at this point you struggling like this
is not going to be helpful secure
Moochie saying that he's humoring the
president when the president says that
there was no Russian hacking okay the
four top intelligence agencies the DNI
the FBI the CIA all these places right
say that there was Russian interference
in the election not hacking election
machines it's not Russian election
hacking but there was a hack on the DNC
perpetrated by the Russian government
and disseminated by the Russian
government in order to damage our
electoral system okay Skinner Moochie is
like how is that helpful Trump spent the
last several months battling this rumor
that he doesn't actually think this half
and and so he's not taking the Russian
threat seriously and then squirming she
goes out there and says well somebody
said this to me and tapper goes well who
and he goes
trump is this the mark of a brilliant
communications strategist I don't think
so and you see this permeating the
communications the communication scheme
is that there are the people who want
Trump to say the right thing and then
there are the people who are just going
to repeat whatever Trump tells them so
you have you have scarer Moochie coming
out and saying that he may not actually
support the sanctions bill and then you
had Sarah Huckabee Sanders saying the
Trump does support the sanctions bill
you had scaramouche's saying we talked
about pardons then you had Jay Sekulow
saying pardons are not on the table
right I mean like they're contradicting
each other seculow is his lawyer so
seculow is trying to protect him from
himself
here's seculow talking about the pardon
issue in that tweet stated something
that's rather unremarkable and that is
that under the Constitution that our
article two section two the president
has the authority to pardon but I want
to be clear on this George we have not
and continue to not have conversations
with the President of the United States
regarding pardons pardons have not been
discussed and pardons are not on the
table with regard to the issue of a a
president pardoning himself there's a
big academic discussion going on right
now an academic debate you've got
professor tribe arguing one point you
got professor Turley arguing another
point while it makes for interesting
academic discussions let me tell you
what the legal team is not doing
we're not researching the issue because
the issue of Barnes is not on the table
okay see this is what the legal team
isn't researching it we're not really
looking at it here's scaramouche
yesterday let's cut through it all okay
you and I right here let's clear it all
you're basically saying that that tweet
is suggesting that the president's going
to pardon himself and every one of his
family members hi what do you what are
you suggesting I'm saying he's not he's
not going to do that I don't know buddy
I am suggesting one thing the president
waited about pardons and I'm asking you
who is he thinking about pardoning
that's all quite adjusting that'll why
didn't the president's thinking about
pardoning nobody because it has been
coming up a lot there's an undercurrent
of nonsensical stuff because he has
asked advisers about it
welcome come on Jake he's not allowed to
this is the problem with the whole
system he's the press
the united states if i turn to one of my
staff members at skybridge i ask them a
question they run out to the news media
and tell everything i'm thinking about
is that fair to the president okay so
you basically saying the Trump is
talking about pardons so again this is
not get your communication strategy in
order guys and I think that the term
administrator again if you want it to be
successful you need him to to hem it in
but that's not what's happened right
Kellyanne Conway everybody is now
auditioning it is the apprentice I mean
it really is everyone who's auditioning
for a White House job is more interested
in pleasing Trump on TV than in actually
making sure that he implements policies
that are going to make him worthy of
reelection Kellyanne Conway yesterday
says you should be super you should be
so happy that he's tweeting I mean come
on like it's great good he's tweeting
anybody also right there with a lot
about television he tweet well so you
should be happy about that you don't
happy that we all emotional aged you
should be happy that we have such an
engaged president but you know 99% of
what the president doesn't says is not
on Twitter it's done in the Oval Office
it's done in his cabinet meetings of
meetings with different cabinet members
okay that's fine except for the fact
that when she says you should be happy
he's so engaged this is what Trump
tweeted this morning quote Swezey Adam
Schiff the totally biased Congress been
looking into Russia okay so far so good
spends all of his time on TV pushing the
demos excuse and you're spending all of
your time watching him on TV tweeting
about it like why is this useful this is
just not useful again I would like to
see some some victories come on okay I
was promised winning will tear the
winning where's the winning come on
let's do it okay and I don't mean
winning like he stands on his top coat
he makes chance from the top of the key
I mean like actual conservative wins
that we can put our finger on and say
this is why we elected Republicans to
high office and look not all of that is
fault Congress isn't doing its job
Congress is incompetent this is why
presidential leadership is necessary
Congress knows that there is no risk to
them in a voiding trunk at this point in
just bucking Trump Trump has to make it
risky Trump has to go out there and make
the case for his agenda and then he has
to go out there and say to Congress if
you buck my agenda there will be
consequences
okay Obama did this even Bush did this
Trump isn't doing that right now and
it's very frustrating because he's
letting Congress off the hook Congress
is letting itself off the hook and Trump
is more focused on surrounding himself
with people who are going to agree with
him so Kellyanne Conway is spending time
talking about Robert Waller again a must
is going to fire Robert Muller this is a
waste of time so maybe you will fire
Robert Mullin but if he fires the
special counsel all hell is going to
break loose because that special
candidate that will look like a cover-up
when you start firing the special
counsel before the special counsel even
comes up with anything I mean this is
not good you can see the White House
already paving the way for this here's
Conway doing this routine why doesn't
the president just want Muller to prove
that Trump is right that Russia was a
hoax
why doesn't even Muller to go ahead and
confirm that for him well is it mr.
Muller and his band of Democratic donors
doing that aren't they trying to do that
okay so she's obviously claiming the
mullahs bias again president Trump
considered him for FBI director okay so
it's dead this is all it's a wait the
reason why doesn't matter why doesn't
Matt why can't I just be happy why can't
I just sit here and be happy the reason
I can't be happy is because the
Democrats are sitting over here just
waiting the Democrats don't have to do
anything all they have to do is sit over
here and wait for Trump to implode all
over himself and they're waiting in the
wings with a policy that is going to be
so horrible that is going to destroy
everything that Trump is supposedly
trying to build okay so here is Chuck
Schumer yesterday talking about what
comes next for Obamacare this is the
senate minority leader who if he gets
lucky could be the senate majority
leader by 2018 and certainly has a very
good shot at it by 2020 if things keep
going this way here's Chuck Schumer one
of the world's worst leftist talking
about what the Democrats are going to do
if they take power again then we're
going to look at broader things
single-payer is one of them that is our
Medicare well sure many things are on
the table Medicare for people above 55
is on the table a buy into Medicare is
on the table buy into Medicaid is on the
table okay so they're talking about a
full-scale nationalization of the health
care system essentially getting rid of
insurance companies altogether and
instead everybody would just work for
the government basically the government
would decide what people are paid this
would completely destroy the American
health care system as we know it and
they are talking about doing this openly
now because Trump care has failed
because Trump can't make the case and
I'm sorry firing off a few tweets and
riding around in a fire truck is not
going to do it when you're really when
you're real focus is on Muller and
scaramouche II and the TV and if
somebody's on to be praising you in in
terms that are sick of phanzig enough
for your liking
okay please mr. president focus please
for the love of the country for the love
of the country please focus on pressing
your agenda
okay I didn't go
for you but you can prove me wrong you
proved me wrong with the election you
can prove me wrong again prove that you
can do this job
prove that you are capable I'm gaining
the sort of wins that we were told you
again not cursing at the media anybody
can do that that's not a hard job
contrary to popular opinion that's a
very easy job all I'm asking is that you
give me some reasons to praise you
because I would like to do so you're my
president okay they're all of our
presidents even though people don't like
you okay before I get to things I like
and things I hate I first want to say
thank you to some new sponsors so why do
we have stage country's taxes Wars
when did globalization start why does
history matter wonder II has a brand new
podcast now from a PhD historian Patrick
Lyman it's called tides of history and
it is really fascinating I've listened
to the first three episodes I believe
the intro and the first couple episodes
it's really well done and he takes on
some issues in history that haven't
really been covered too much so he takes
on the period 1350 to 1650 and he talks
about why the roots of the modern world
start there like why are there states in
the first place why aren't we just a
bunch of separate fiefdom
how was it that states became the
predominant way of doing business why is
it that there's free trade how did these
trade routes get started
how did capitalism begin where to
globalization start right all of these
forces that shape our modern world begin
in that post medieval era just before
the during the Renaissance era and just
before the just before the Enlightenment
and that's the period that he takes on
in tides of history really well
researched interesting stuff he makes
what could be very dry history very
interesting go listen to the first
episode of tides of history by searching
for tides of history on your podcast
player or Google tides of history today
go to link on the screen and it is
listen you know you can listen you can
learn you can subscribe the podcast
again
it's called tides of history and it's
really good you should go check it out
at iTunes SoundCloud wherever you get
your podcast subscribe and give it a
listen I love history and this is really
good history even if I disagree with
some of it it's really informative and
interesting okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like I've started reading
this book heavy reading I've been into
some doing some heavy philosophy reading
in the recent past this is a book that
was recommended to me actually by a
professor Jordan Peterson over in over
and
Canada when I was up there giving a
speech and he was talking about
philosophy and the in the philosophy of
mind and the philosophy of God and he
recommended this book the metaphysical
club a story of ideas in America by
Lewis Manan it won the Pulitzer Prize
and it is a really interesting read
relatively easy to read actually it's
about for real thinkers at the beginning
of the 20th century Oliver Wendell
Holmes of course the Supreme Court
Justice William James is the father of
modern American psychology charles
sanders peirce who's been largely
forgotten but was a logician of the
first order and it's it's and john dewey
who's sort of their intellectual heir
and the father of the progressive
movement the reason this is important is
because you can see how deeper
philosophy is siphoned into what the
West's philosophy is today John Dewey
was the father of progressivism in the
United States you can't understand the
modern day barack obama democratic party
without reading about John Dewey and his
ideological forebears and why it is that
the natural law the natural law
philosophy of our founders was cast
aside in favor of the legal positivism
of people like Oliver Wendell Holmes and
the and the progressivism of John Dewey
so you can check it out the metaphysical
club really good read okay other things
that I liked is that I was just a
beautiful video so there's a stepson who
he was adopted who you know his mother
married a stepfather an 11 year old
Tyler from Conyers Georgia he wanted he
goes to his stepfather and reads him a
letter and asked him officially to
become his father via adoption
his stepfather has been in Tyler's life
since the boy was 18 months old and
first it was set up as though this was a
baby shower and then and then they start
and then they start taping it here is
here's Tyler reading a letter it is
stuff yet ok cool what we well I first
like thought me otherwise
a lot of funny you taught me a little
bit you can read nice with almost all of
them you gave me more than what I we I
know that we were supposed to be other
than funny people even say I look like
that I had been your channel and we'll
sit I'll remember but of the media comes
illegally when you please a lot that's
just awesome and it does it does show
you know honestly one of the things
that's been missing in so many
communities black and white all over the
country now is the presence of a father
figure in people's lives and that's just
beautiful and it shows you that fathers
cannot be replaced okay I understand
that we're now society that thinks that
that sexes have no differentiation and
that to women is the same as a man and a
woman or that mother can do the same
thing as a father you can do both not
true okay fathers are necessary I know
this from my own children I know this my
own father okay fathers are necessary
and and if a child is lucky enough to
have a wonderful father there's nothing
that can replace that it's just
incredible so yeah this just a beautiful
video and it's wonderful that that they
were able to catch that on tape that we
could all experience it because it's
just a wonderful thing okay time for
some things I hate so on the flip side
on the flipside of this beauty is utter
stupidity
so Huffington Post had a tweet yesterday
and so they tweeted at this tweet with
this picture will show you that I want
to get the exact tweet if I can find it
they said that this picture will show
you that periods are not just for women
ok and this is a picture of a woman who
has a butch haircut and and you can't
really see the bottom of the photo she
has bled through her pants and said
periods are not just for women
hashtag bleeding well trans no it turns
out periods are just for women
ok I'm sorry that you think your man but
it turns out that you are in fact a
biological woman and that is why I
cannot have my period today nor can
Malthus nor I believe commercial so all
of this is just a bunch of nonsense and
it's so stupid I saw that there's some
amazing conversation online it's just
incredible how stupid everyone has
become this is amazing conversation
online with it with some sort of trans
advocate where somebody said ok so if
I'm a dude and I have sex with a trans
woman am I is that a gay sexual act
right the trans woman still has the male
parts and says no that is straight sex
only if you are a woman and you had sex
with the man with the male parts who
thinks he's a woman would that be
lesbian ok then
alrighty that's kind of ok the this
person who put up this picture of caste
clemmer posted a picture of herself
bleeding from the crotch and the PO and
posted a poem and said y'all know I'm
trans and queer which and what that
means for me all around is something
that's neither there nor here it's
poetry it's a happy scary middle ground
so when I talk to ender inclusion and I
wrote these rhymes to help you see I'm
not trying to bring up something shallow
periods are honestly pretty traumatic
for me see my life is very clearly
marked like a red border cut up a nation
a time before and a time beyond the mark
of my first menstruation is she now
comparing this to like the Civil War a
red border cut up the nation so let me
take you back to the details I can still
recall of the day I gained my first
period or no and the day I lost it all I
was 15 and still happy running around
I'll chest bared and Buck climbing trees
digging holes and no one gave a single
bleep I think I think I mean I think my
mom was worried so I went and grew out
my locks a sign I was normal still a
girl and painted a neon sign for my
gender box so the day I got my period my
god a day so proud this little and Rho F
cup kid had been bestowed the straights
its shroud okay I'm sorry that you're
mentally ill I mean like really I please
seek help I mean it really is sad it
makes you kind of sick to your stomach
honestly that somebody is living in this
much pain because obviously this person
is living in serious pain you're not a
man and pretending to your man is going
to bring you nothing but misery okay
believing you're a man this is something
that requires I don't know that there's
a great treatment available but society
pretending that you are a man having a
period is not the solution to your
problems nor is it the solution to the
problems of many gender confused kids
who are younger than 15 years old look
do what you want okay it's your life do
what you want but don't if you insist
the periods are not just for women you
are doing a grave disservice to both
women and young boys who are believing
things that are biologically incorrect
it's just it's just come on I mean the
idea that it's not an imposition on
society of course it's an imposition on
society as I say go do what you want no
one really cares but when you start
tweeting out things like periods are not
just for women and you're featured at
the front page of The Huffington Post
requiring that everyone who agrees with
basic biology is somehow forced to agree
with your lie that you are a man it
should no no okay other things that I
hate the final thing that I hate so
Richard Dawkins who is an atheist is a
he has now been banned from Berkeley
California there was a benefit event for
chaos for a KPFA which is a listener
funded station in Berkeley California
tickets were snapped ahead of the ant
ideas plan talked on August 9th they
cancelled the event because it turns out
that he said some mean things about
Muslims they're fine with him saying
mean things about Christians but as soon
as Richard Dawkins said some mean things
about Muslims was all over and KPFA
cancelled the event they say they
emphatically support serious free speech
but we do not support abusive speech
he's criticized religion publicly for
decades and he's been no platformed he
says he has strongly condemned misogyny
homophobia and violence of Islamism of
which Muslims particularly Muslim women
are the
prime victims but he is too conservative
for Berkeley so he must not be allowed
at their radio station he is a far
leftist by the way Richard Dawkins he is
not even close to a right winger he's a
militant atheist who hates religion and
is I believe a socialist on politics so
this is so this idea that I mean you
talk about the left eating their own
okay I lied there's one more thing I
have to show because it's just it's an
important thing so Charlie guard his
parents finally gave up on their appeal
to the courts today the court said that
the kid deserved to die which is just
horrifying
they said the kid has a right to die
essentially and and so this is his
parents you know we tried to get him
over to the US I reached out to a few
Congress people were trying to get him
citizenship so we could extradite him
from the UK they gave up their appeal
because at this point it doesn't matter
anymore he's basically brain dead and
this is the parents reading the reading
their announcement his body heart and
soul they soon because his spirit will
live on for eternity and he will make a
difference to people's lives for years
to come we will make sure that okay so
just I hope that they do I hope that
they keep fighting for the right to life
and the right for the family to make
decisions that the government should not
be making but this notion that death
with dignity means that you have to die
in a hospital rather than striving to
live it's one of my pet peeves you know
when people have cancer you hear very
often oh he's a fighter he'll make it
okay whether you live from cancer or not
has very little to do with whether
you're a fighter I know a lot of
fighters have died of cancer and I know
a lot of people who don't seem like
particularly strong people who live
through cancer this idea that health
problems are some sort of indicia of
moral character it's stupid and it's
also it's also immoral and immoral to
suggest that death with dignity is more
important that this child this child
died sedated in the hospital rather than
the parents doing the best they can to
save the child's life even if you don't
appreciate the kids quality of life it's
not your decision to make
okay so we'll be back here tomorrow with
all of the latest updates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]